here in FL thank you very much for the
agreeing to do this you've been a guest
of the Nexus Institute for a couple of
times I want to ask you what was the
Nexus S it mean to you but for me
Nexus Institute it's an institution who
is taking care do you think about what
we have to do to make I think the human
persons more conscious and more
responsible about all the things they
have to do with education with
sensitivity with heart in with also with
the social life and I think it's it's a
way to combine the forces of
intellectual people of philosophers of
historians of artists of people from
philosophy security to bring them
together to a port his opinions and try
to found new stimulation to resolve the
actual situation in many of our
countries in Europe special which we
have lost a little bit the balance in
the society and we have lost also the
possibility to make changes they bring
the people closer to the earth into the
very nice education I know you're
yourself as well involved in all kind of
projects to bring arts closer to the
people can you tell us a bit about the
things you're doing to bring arts to
people well in first instance of what I
am doing it's basically it's to bring
the music to the different holes in
different countries to make people
the experience 202 to listen to concerts
which was not only a project with music
from the Baroque or from the Renaissance
but by train in the last already 14 15
years it's to bring also music to the
history music to the relation between
different societies with between Orion
accident or inside from world like
Balkans or like Ottoman Empire and I
think we need to use the music to
understand the history because the music
it's as yes Kennedy has say music it's a
lot the really life history of the human
being because when we listen a song from
another time you are we are doing the
same experience of the people from this
time and then we have the emotion and we
have the real perspective the global
census to make us to understand this
historical context and I think music can
help so it's very important from the
intercultural they're known for these
our projects with Jerusalem with my
Nostrum with the supreme port Istanbul
and recently the Balkans and all these
projects showing the people the
communities they are in in the different
countries enemies they can be together
it with the music they can found harmony
and I think is a very important to
remember the music it's probably today
one of the last bridges that we can have
bringing people from different buildings
from different religions from different
cultures together especially if we do
music from these different traditions
together with our early music because in
Europe the medieval music has the same
basic Metroid's and very style very
similar to the oriental music and then
when we play troubadours music hm - and
we play music from the canticles music
from the seven until the 14th century
before the we invented the polyphony and
the counterpoint all this music before
which is also mana D and based on and on
improvisation and lamentation it has the
same methods as they have been orient
and then we can found very nice ways -
you've been participating in rock demons
project at the university of life what
would you say is the most important
lesson life taught you well I think the
result what we are what we are as a
persons is a result of all our
experience of all our traumas of our
conflicts and of all the influences that
we have receiving life in from of family
from our mother or father from the
teachers from anything everything I
personally I think we have to help
people making them more conscience how
important of the first ten years in the
life of our children I have say this
before in the end end-edge you think
after 10 years we can learn but we the
personality the character all the
essential things that makes us as a
personality as a real human are already
very well defined and I think this 10
first years of the life is the moment
where we can really give these children
a sense of
opening of curiosity of Education of be
a good person of everything it's it's
the moment of this and this is it's not
in the school it's a home I think
sometimes we we done things enough how
important is this the school of life at
home in the beginning of her life and I
think in my experience I have I think
learn the most important things in this
period of my life until 1415 years and
I'm very I have learned beautiful things
but also I have suffer for other things
but they have also made me understanding
things you know and I think we today
maybe we protected too much childrens
for things that we have to give the
chose the petunia also to make
experience to to be able to also to to
resolve themselves things in a certain
dimension of course you know because
only the things you experience in your
life you will assimilate education is
not only to feel different aspects of
how to be a good person but it's to
experience them life and to take the
consequences of these and into our to
learn from the daily experience you have
in your life well this will be my last
question you just sat there those first
10 years were so essential to you can
you remember something that really
inspired you from that period that you
still take with you in your heart I have
many many seems that they inspired me in
this but I will say maybe one of the
things they have marked very strong my
life was when I was 10
but one thing was when it was six listen
to a boy call from the school and it was
really very happy to listen this is
children singing but one thing they have
I think has changed my life very strong
was when I was 10 I was suffering from a
very sever inflection it afforded in
century and I was very near to die
because they didn't have found what
happens in one way they had discover was
a typhus it was very late and my heart
was still working very slow then means I
have been mostly 2 and 1/2 months in
recovering in him without possibility to
move and and in the in the home and in
this time I remember I have discovered
the pleasure of reading and the pleasure
of listen to music and he saved my life
because listen the music music has bring
me so much energy and breathing I was
able to to fly to go I remember I have
read Pushkin
Jews band and different books it was
like a so things at home and everything
that was starting a book for me was like
I was traveling and been in another
world and I think this has been have a
very strong influence in my evolution
later thank you very much it's far all
might say thank you
you